so in your bio on IMDB it says as you
went to law school mm-hmm
yeah I I'm both the left and right brain
person that's my mom and dad
unfortunately god bless them my dad's
side really dominated my thinking for
many many years I remember I remember
being like I like senior in high school
I told my dad I wanted to be a chef I've
been cooking since I was like eight
years old and he was like kritis what
kind of job is that you know the
computers computer as you know so my
point is that really got inculcated you
know in my brain so although I had a
very artistic side of creative side I
studied theater as an undergrad was one
of my majors and I started creating
photos I started doing black and white
photography in college on my own I
bought a book about a camera I had all
that creative side but I ran away from
it I I just bought into the conventional
path the conventional security of life
so I did a whole series of jobs
including being the English and drama
teacher at a public middle school
including teaching sex ed that's one of
my claims to fame I went to seminary I
was studying to be a pastor and then I
went to law school and that was just
like I was in my first year of law
school I really enjoyed it
you know studying law is just really
fascinating and being around so many
smart people is really invigorating but
a series of things happened and I
realized like it's now this is it this
is my this is my last chance to decide
between those two you know if I stay in
law school and I graduate I'm gonna have
so much debt that I will not have any
other choice but to professionally be an
attorney or something in that realm I
won't be able to completely devote
myself to
anything creative so you know over the
course of three or four weeks the
realization just became clear that I
needed to leave so I came back home I
swallowed my pride I went from being at
a really highly rated law school back to
it being a substitute teacher living
with my folks at like 30 years old
so you know it was a it was a big piece
of humble pie in the sense of having to
face people but inside I was very
confident of my decision very confident
and that was a few years ago and since
then you know I've just been working on
I'm trying to learn how to make films
well so when you made this decision to
be law school what did your fellow
classmates say that was actually an
incredibly revealing moment for me I
actually sent an email to all my peers
all my colleagues just so everybody knew
from me why I left and I got a good
number of responses from the students
many of them were like hey that's great
good job we'll miss you but a few were
like saying they wish they had my
courage they wish they could do what I
did they envied my devotion to
creativity that to me was it was kind of
sad you know it was really sad that
there are people there not for the right
reasons there are plenty of really good
reasons to go to law school but there's
a lot more bad reasons it's political
and unfortunately many students go to
law school for those reasons so that was
very interesting so there's a lot of
closeted creative types in law school
simply because there's more and simply
because they don't know what else to do
in life or they want the money or the
security like me so that was that was a
very interesting response
you